thanks everyone so there are two names
here that you'll see unfortunately Neil
got six this morning and sent me
progress reports all through the morning
of how he was getting worse and worse
and having enjoyed a birthday party for
his three-year-old son he then put
himself to bed
so the talk today is going to be about
our experience jpmorgan of running a
Python infrastructure massive scale the
final part of the talk was going to be a
live coding demo done by Neil but he's
not going to be here to do that and so I
won't attempt his live coding I will
give a kind of impressionistic view over
the slides that he was going to present
and then I'll quickly switch to
questions that you might have so first
of all just to introduce JP Morgan so JP
Morgan is one of the biggest banks in
the world not really a household name in
the UK as far as banks go pretty big a
couple of nice round numbers there I
guess the nice system around this number
of all is to revenue is a hundred
billion dollars last year so that's
quite large and the bank has two hundred
fifty two thousand employees globally so
that is that is a very large company now
on the tech side most people don't think
of JP Morgan as a technology company
maybe for you guys because you're a lot
closer to to these types of things you
do but JP Morgan has 44,000 people the
working technology and the total budget
for technology is nearly ten thousand
ten billion dollars so very large tech
organization and within that Python is
very very widely used
I thought about listing some of the air
the Python is used within the bank but
basically it's used in most parts of the
bank to solve pretty much every
conceivable problem that people have so
I won't with them more talk about how we
actually use Python in our day-to-day
work so the topics I'm going to cover
today will be focusing on a cleaner
thenor is a Python based trading
platform that is widely used in across
the investment bank and JPMorgan and I
work in the Athena core team so it's a
team of about a hundred and forty people
that build the core infrastructure for
that trading platform then I'll go on to
describing how we actually make the
platform work at the scale that we do
and the code base is thirty five million
lines of code at the moment so that's
pretty large and then touch on the bits
so Athena is a platform that started in
2006 originally targeted to be risk
management framework for ethics options
so very much as conceived as a start
from scratch project to do things in a
way that enable developers to be very
productive to meet the needs of a
trading business that was trading
complex derivatives the starting point
was in ethics options the users with
traders of ethics options and some
extent the sales team there and the work
of tailoring the platform for the needs
of the desk is done by small teams small
desk align teams so typically there will
be teams of
the four or five developers working with
a couple of quants who would be building
out say the FX options specific
functionality or FX cash or precious
metals I used to run the precious metals
technology team and and we had five
people between London and New York and
and this functionality was all built
using the underlying platform called
Athena built by the Athena core team now
the overall development approach for
this was focused 100% about rapid
application development when you're
starting a brand new project that says
we're going to do something as ambitious
as building a trading platform you're
coming into a business that basically
says we don't think you can plus a lot
of other technology teams that say we
don't think you can either because if
you're successful you'll replace us so
you start with a small kind of
skunkworks project that then kind of
runs like crazy to try and build enough
functionality to prove that you can
actually do it and you have to build the
credibility as you go so that that meant
that from the start in 2006 they had to
make very very tight decisions about
what the infrastructure was going to be
and how it was going to be supported so
they built a very narrow stack of
tightly integrated Python components
really pushing the limits of what Python
was at the time and these are
screenshots from the training manual
that I used when I first joined in 2010
showing some of these components so
there's a launcher for the trading
applications trade blotter showing
elements of deals booked a risk report
and then a chat application called pins
now the different colors of the
different people so you can see
instantly what's gone wrong in which
part of the business the the bits that
you don't see from this in the stack are
underlying at all
all is object-oriented database that we
call Hydra that basically enables
trading to take place simultaneously in
all the different trading centers around
the world does optimistic writes into
each of the local location so New York
and say Singapore London and then will
replicate transactions between those
databases and if you have designed
things well there will be no conflicts
and everything will merge and you will
quickly get a consistent view of your
global trading position you've got
conflicting rights in different
locations and you'll screw it up very
quickly so clever use of having simple
technologies and then Hydra is based on
pickling Python objects and very simple
it's actually based on soap if anyone
was using Python around the year 2000
births are very much extended for a
global trading business also the one of
the decisions that was made very early
on was to run all of the source code and
the development in a mono repo and the
idea was you'd have developers globally
small teams on all the trading desks and
you want everyone to be developing from
the same codebase now this was a long
time ago in the very early stages of the
project when I say had an informal
software development lifecycle that
basically means it had no real software
development lifecycle no real separation
between durbin production things would
break all the time but somehow it was
small teams that knew the stack well
that knew one another well that were
able to recover from anything that went
wrong and it was a great foundation and
you know you need to you need to run
quickly at the start to get the
on the board to have the credibility
with the business to then reinvest in
growth so the the scope of Athena as it
took off grew enormously so I joined in
2010 which was four years into Athena
just as it was expanding from FX to
precious metals and precious metals is
traded a lot like a foreign currency so
so precious leveraged a lot of the FX
stuff you have vaults we're full of gold
bars and things like that you need to
track and the next business on board was
commodities and then following years
credit and rates and then parts of
equities but equities has a lot of
really high volume trading that Python
struggles to cope with but Athena grew
through largely also the controls around
what we were doing increased enormously
so anyone who's worked in banking knows
that you have lots of different teams
that check what each silo was doing to
make sure they're doing things right and
in particular we have market risk teens
credit risk teams valuation control
groups to check that traders were
pricing things correctly all of these
people started off running their own
price pricing stacks to do independent
valuations and risk calculations what
realized very quickly was that it makes
no sense to do that where you have so
many different parties across the bank
having their own models their own
versions of the truth and to a large
degree they have converged on using
Athena to to give a single view and a
single consistent methodology for
pricing everything so that's how clean
sort of grew subsequently and right now
we're at the phase of a whole new growth
in the use of of the Athena platform for
data science and machine learning and
that brings very different challenges
and I'll get onto that later in the talk
so these these screenshots here
a more recent version of Athena they
look a little bit more modern this is
from Athena trade at desktop which has
been the the main GUI platform for the
last three years now over the 12-year
history of Athena the the size of the
code base and the number of developers
involved in that has has grown
enormously this graph is the number of
active developers per month and so and
these are people that are committing
code there's a whole bunch of other
people that might write code but not
actually commit it into the production
code base so we have 1,600 developers a
month committing code the number of
commits per month is around 60,000 and
the total number of files in the source
control system is around 500,000 so this
is a large code base and essentially
when we're developing code and you will
want to see whether someone has written
some code before that does what you want
and you do it's all that we use is
called glimpse you glimpse through other
code that's being written you'll be
searching through a code base it's this
big interestingly you'll see here
commits per month has a dip each year
and this is an end-of-year code freeze
no one wants systems to break around the
end of year especially with people away
for Christmas holidays so around 2011
there was code freeze instituted before
2011 people just went healthfully by
committing code regardless that's a sign
of the maturity
the business so when you have a
situation where you've got 60,000
commits a week to a code base it's quite
a difficult challenge to see how do you
actually make that work safely it feels
like the whole world is changing
underneath you so I'll talk a bit about
that so from the start with Athena one
of the aims that everyone has worked for
is to make a scale for developers to be
productive and that's important because
we want to deliver functionality and we
want to deliver it quickly and also we
want developers to be happy
there's nothing destroy is the happiness
of a development team than having a
whole lot of bureaucracy that they have
to step through and we see in some other
parts of the bank that operate in a far
more traditional way there forever
preparing for a release or preparing
test environments or preparing to
migrate and do things like that
and somehow in our world that that
doesn't happen we just write our code
and and get it into production now the
way we do that is through continuous
deployment to different levels now we
have the sort of core so we split the
code in two into two halves so the
bottom half is the core Python
distribution and so this is standard
Python plus mainly by binary libraries
that we have decided make up the sort of
the core of the core of Athena and then
the second level is application Python
code which is effectively what all of
our developers in their organization
write and that has a different process
so I'll briefly talk about this one
first and then
a couple of slides go through that the
the SDLC that we have for the Python
code that front-office developers write
all the time is very simple you write
the code you write test cases for it and
committed into production and then
there's a stage gate where someone from
the team that that code is sensitive to
needs to bless it and this is this is
the the kind of the approval stage for
going into production
once code has been blessed then it can
be pushed in production and from that
point it's live and so anyone globally
running that application or an
application that uses that library will
get the latest version of it and that
means that the whole development
experience is something that you know I
guess very rewarding and for a trading
desk if they see that there is something
that is broken a particular type of deal
is not working or something like that
then we can do an immediate fix and get
that pushed into production for them
right away there was a question over
there the trading platform do so so in
the in the narrow sense the trading
platform is you have sales people that
are taking orders from customers for
particular financial deals and so they
need to price a particular so structured
deal to that customer the customer might
be a hedge fund or an industrial user of
metals or someone wanting to hedge a
currency exposure
or any number of em customers they they
will want to do some kind of financial
deal with the bank they get a price for
that it's quoted they accept that then a
trader will book that deal into the
systems and normally that will involve
the bank taking on a risk a financial
risk for the customer and there may not
be an exact match for that product in
the market what the customer wants so
the trading desk will split apart that
that financial transaction into simpler
things that are traded on the markets
and they will hedge their exposure like
that and there's a trading desk you make
your money from the spread between the
price that the customer pays and and
what you can do to to hedge that risk in
other markets so you need to understand
the risk exposure that you have from
taking on a deal you need to be able to
book the right components of that say
their futures trades or things like that
in other markets and then as you have a
portfolio of trades as the markets
market prices and risks are moving you
may need to reach portfolios
continuously so that that's the kind of
the trading desk view of the world and
then there's a whole lot of other things
around you know settlement settling
trades regulatory reporting financial
and accounting aspects and and so the
feeder trading system does many of the
parts of this end-to-end process plus a
whole lot more analysis around and
figuring out basically how to run every
every part of a trading business okay so
so for this application level Python
code the idea is that as soon as
code has been saved has been blessed and
formally pushed into production through
the software development lifecycle it's
there to be used for any application
I'll talk a bit more about some of the
controls we have around that so that
that works smoothly but first talk about
how we manage staging of new versions of
the binary Python distribution so
essentially we have one version of the
Python distribution which is Python
talks about its libraries being with
batteries included well the Athena
Python distribution is sort of batteries
and steroids included so full
distribution is about five gigabytes and
this is something that is pushed out to
run on all of the machines whether it's
Windows or Linux machines and clusters
they all run the same set of packages we
are using Python to seven internally I'm
talk more about why that is at the end
and a question if you like to outside in
a question but yes and that will change
there are there are good reasons for
that but I'll talk about that at the end
so the idea is that this collection of
packages gets upgraded each week and we
think of these versions of the packages
is a bit like a train so each week the
sort of candidate for release prod needs
to prod then port the arm the previous
pride becomes prod dot old and these are
accessed by having setting up a Python
path but has
directories for all of these and so
these like build numbers and so you can
see that between prod and and then next
week's prod do there was what's that
317 417 more build that product latest
is continually built version of that
with a whole lot of unit testing going
on and then when that gets cut to a
release it goes to product new and the
developers and all the dev
infrastructure run on prod new for a
week to shake out any incompatibility
problems and then the live trading
system runs on prod and then the old
version of pride is kept round for
another week so that if the process of
rolling out prod uncovers any unknown
bugs then particular applications within
Athena can run for a while on that old
code while at some while that's resolved
and this is a really simple way of doing
a distribution with the downside that
the full set of packages is 5 gigabytes
times 4 so that's a 25 gigabyte
distribution and this is one of the
things we're trying to solve now when
moving to you know cloud-based
infrastructure you're setting up your
your code in some kind of container and
shipping it out and we try to make it
easy for people to switch between these
environments because it's important to
recover quickly so here from our main
application launcher you can just right
click on right click on an application
and run it using any of these other
environments so that's that makes it
super easy to to run from prod but have
the safety of being able to roll back
now the the more interesting layer here
is how we manage the continuous
deployment for from
the application level code and the way
we do that is the source code is not
stored on the file system it's stored in
in Hydra our global object oriented
database and so when a
athina application runs it has a couple
of parameters here specifying what to
use and so the source database PS is is
front source so real time forwards view
of boolean looking at gold XA u and runs
on prod source and the way that that
works in practice is within Python use
path books to have an import hook and
have a special importer that rather than
loading source code from the file system
will go out to this database and pull
back the source code or more accurately
the compiled source code to run that and
we have wrapped versions of a lot of
libraries so like the standard Python
module of logging if you load that it's
loaded from the file system if you load
live blogging which is the Python
wrapped version all that sort of hooked
up into all the infrastructure then it
actually comes comes from Hydra and we
can show that these modules are just
normal objects by by opening the object
database and reading them and the actual
way they they get executed is the
standard way from modules so that's
that's the way that we're able to do
continuous and instant deployment of
source code globally at this scale
if you want to learn more about import
hooks so there's a couple of pets that
have been written about that and also
some some projects that are on github or
on Wi-Fi that will use the
importance now as part of making of
helping it make developers productive
another thing that we do is with
object-oriented database be able to do
what we call unions of the database a
lot of the time and traditional IT
organizations you know they're creating
test environments and sort of then the
data gets needs to get refreshed and
everything like that whereas the way we
run things we're able to specify
combinations of databases just with a
semicolon
and the infrastructure transparent we
will stack these together any rights
going to the front database and reads
will happen from the back ones so we use
that for archiving for instance so you
can have the main production database
and then moved old deals out of it
that you could put those old deals in
archive databases and have a transparent
way of accessing it operating
geographically you can specify an
individual geographical host rather than
picking the nearest and if you're
writing tests you do something like this
where you have a test database in the
front your line of business operational
database in the middle and then some
common bank why it's a reference data
database in the back and it will you
know you run your unit tests the test
objects will end up here you can check
them there and then you can nuke that
database and it will be clear again the
next on your own tests so that's a very
convenient way of not having to have
expensive operations to to set up
environments for doing testing also from
source databases you could do with the
prod sauce the PS but we also have
personal staging areas and so these
operate in the same way your own staging
area is stacked in front of the
the backend database and and so you have
a personal area there if you want to do
development as part of a team for one
project you can create a staging area
like that although we discourage that
because you really want everyone to be
working at head we don't want
long live development that gets too far
away from the main code and then finally
as part of the software development
process whenever code is needing to be
reviewed or to get committed or get
blessed those source files are packaged
up into their own staging area so that
they can be kept so they can be first of
all seen by the person that's reviewing
it but then also kept for audit purposes
now this when you got all this code
changing around you then there you might
want to create some kind of stability
and so there are ways where we can
freeze these changes at certain points
in time so maybe at the time an
application starts up in the morning you
want to freeze the source code there so
now to make all of this work this is a
whole lot of tooling but it's hidden
behind the scenes we use a customized
version of Visual Studio that integrates
the version control information so we
say who files sensitive to the reviewing
commit infrastructure and see see
everything there and also see which
people own files so all of the history
around the way we are coding is is right
there in Visual Studio for everyone to
use this tooling lowers the barrier for
improving the quality quite strict
controls around test coverage and so on
things like prep mark checks these are
checks at any time pricing sensitive
code gets pushed you compared
prices before after sometimes that will
reveal bugs sometimes it will reveal
known changes in how something gets
priced and in that case the trading
desks need to sign off the pricing
changes before they can go live
but this tooling doesn't get in the way
of the developers and it means that we
can all focus on writing code quickly
now having tooling itself is part of the
story and the other thing is you know
you need to have a big stick to whack
people if they get out of line but
ideally you don't actually want to need
to use that stick at all really it comes
down to having the right kind of culture
this graph shows test coverage for this
is for all of Athena which is there's a
lot of legacy code there so it improved
very slowly so the highlight here is the
coverage controls were instituted here
but test coverage didn't really change
it was only when the software
development lifecycle commit controls
enforced test coverage and things like
that then the test coverage increases
this line here is the example from a
newly set up a small team in Beijing
that some quite quickly was able to
reach the same kind of levels of test
coverage as the rest of the business it
shows and it's having the the
combination of the tooling to make it
easy plus enforcement top down and by
the infrastructure will drive that
change so the you know the end result is
Athena has become a very stable trading
environment used by getting on for 2,000
developers with 15,000 changes a week
but with a relatively conservative code
base using Python 2.7
now that doesn't suit the needs of data
science and the the team I work with is
small
shoot of Athena called Athena research
where we are building the same developer
experience but geared around data
science and machine learning and for
here our our target users are include
not only developers and quotes but also
data scientists you know maybe five
years ago would have been using SAS but
also eventually business users through
you know Jupiter notebooks and
dashboards and things and what we are
building out at the moment is an
environment that uses the newest Python
libraries but still gives access to all
of the the rest of the environments that
a theme that has while in enforcing the
separation between the research
environment and there's more traditional
production environment some of the
challenges that we're solving at the
moment is how to give people across many
lines of business access to data sources
in a way that minimizes the bureaucracy
what's the the right kind of
infrastructure to support scalable
storage calculation GPUs and everything
and how to adopt this software
development lifecycle where you have
models or where you maybe have Jupiter
notebooks which is a combination of code
plus output these all have you know
challenges for established processes and
we're working hard to build all that out
at the moment so we actually just have
must have more minutes than that lift
okay good okay
so this is this is you know I hope has
given you a sense for Athena as a
platform and the type of development
environment that we've tried to create
for very large teams of developers to be
code base I'd just like to finish the
talk with touching on what Neal would
have done for a live coding
demonstration with a data visualization
component that we've just open sourced
called perspective which is a engine for
viewing streaming data this has been the
result of a number of earlier versions
internals JPMorgan it's a fully Python
based version using hdf5 and grid
display with WX Python then another
version that had a more C++ server-side
Grid Engine and the latest version is
one that moves much of the work that an
engine can do to do aggregations and
things like that into the browser using
web assembly so that's up on github is
one of the very first pieces of open
source software from JPMorgan and
something that we hope will be a much
bigger trend in the future I won't go
through these things about the structure
of it neil would have talked about this
that they're the perspectives is is on
github we have one guy who's built a
jupiter lab extension that uses
perspective visualization so if you're
interested in checking that out that's
on the github repo or linked from the
github repo for jupiter lab extensions
the guy who wrote that
name is Tim Payne and we hope to be
presenting about that Jupiter con in New
York in August also I guess I should say
we have a recruiting stand here we
looking for large numbers of
enthusiastic Python programmers for all
types of work for data scientists we
have a massive amount of things going on
so please come and come up to our
recruiting stand come and talk to us and
we can give you a bit of a flavor of
[Music]
so we had that for a couple questions
you you wanted to ask about Python 2.7
versus five and three so I think we
would all dearly like to be on Python
three the one of the downsides of having
a global object store that we used back
in 2006 was it stores Python objects by
pickling them and so when you've got
lots of these you know we have something
like 350 Hydra rings each sure
independent sets of Hydra databases each
one the several hundred gigabytes and
we'll have maybe up to 15 or more
regional replicas so that's a huge job
to migrate from that established
environment into Python 3 but it's
something that we know we have to do
within the next effectively within the
next two years
a lot of preparation is going on for
that at the moment if pandas is going
into life with Python 3 in at the end of
December numpy stopped doing new
features in Python to release from
January and will then just do bug fixes
for 12 months and then stop so
effectively by the end of next year we
have to have migrated this whole trading
business from Python 2.7 to Python 3 so
that's as prompting you know a lot of
other changes as well ok so given
pythons untyped how do you map and a
large gold piece how do you manage
dependencies between modules in
libraries so for managing dependencies
so there's a very large testing
infrastructure behind that that has a
map of the dependencies between all the
different modules so not only as when
you're the standard unit tests that run
when a module is checked in but we have
this this big infrastructure of what we
call ghost tests
but we'll see what modules are calling
any other code and if one module gets
changed anything that uses that will get
all of its units tests unit tests rerun
plus there are a lot more integration
tests and everything else you know
running continuously so it's a very
large testing infrastructure behind it
occasionally things do break but a lot
of the systems are designed to kind of
be to move forward smoothly without
needing explicit data migrations and
that's the key
so obviously you have a customs tag like
a custom database and a custom source
code control system so given the
benefits of hindsight for use of do the
benefits outweigh using a standard like
it lab github and a standard database
versus or integrated but custom stack I
think any any business if you you know
could erase all of history and start
from scratch today you would do things
quite differently but yeah you can't
pretend that that history is not there
and you would not have a business
running if you hadn't been through that
yeah so yeah thene of research there you
know there are large elements of Athena
that work really well we don't want to
throw that away
I think one of the things that Athena
developers realize if they leave Athena
is how much of the infrastructure is
there and it just works and they don't
have to make decisions about that it's
all it's all integrated and so they can
focus on the delivering business
functionality whereas if you you know
you go somewhere else and you think I
get old you know what what do I use for
this what do I use for that you can make
those decisions as an individual but
there's a point where coordinating that
across larger teams then becomes very
hard
yeah yeah I mean one of the one of the
key challenges with Athena research is
saying oh in for the sort of trading
environments for Athena you want
everyone to run the same version of
every module because you want there to
be one answer for everything where it's
in machine learning environment everyone
wants to run the latest versions of the
latest packages but then also to be able
to go back and validate maybe four
models that were developed a year ago
why have they changed so one of the
problems we're solving is how do you
have many more versions of environments
for the underlying binary distribution
and then also for the application codes
that people are using then also of
course the data assets that people are
using those evolve over time and and so
we're in the infrastructure do we want
to provide stability where do we want to
let people these are all complex
engineering and organizational problems
and we try to do that within the
established bank rules they're the
frameworks but then also need to
negotiate a lot of things you know with
compliance and something about well
these need to be done differently for
these reasons and so it's a very
interesting challenge you mentioned
quite a bit about your unit test suite
and how many like how how is so
fundamental to your sort of work for
that scale but how many do you have
exactly or if you can give us like a
rough idea like with with a code base of
that size and how do you kind of ensure
the quality of them as well so that's a
very hard question to answer I mean
every every you had a lot of legacy code
that was live before the unit testing
was mandated and a lot of that code is
old and badly structured and crappy and
the people who wrote it left a long time
ago and it just runs and you just don't
touch it
you can help it but for new code pretty
much every module will have a test
module providing high levels of coverage
and then other modules that all do
cross-cutting functionality so I think
in large case it would be more than a
one-to-one relationship between test
modules and modules of functionality in
terms of the depth of the coverage of
those test cases some some test code is
really thorough and rigorous and of
course there's some other that is you
know kind of goes through the motions
and part of that is around making sure
that the teams that are doing the people
that are doing the blessing of code
enforce higher level of standards on
people that are submitting code that's
not up to scratch so you say that's why
as you down to the teams themselves yeah
the tooling is there to to enforce
metrics and and all of that but are in
their reviews and audits of things and
whatever but very much it comes down to
a culture where people try and do the
best I'm on the whole given that we're
all under incredible time constraints to
do a massive amount with very small
teams you get the balance right so that
it works almost all the time and if it
doesn't work then it's not in the areas
that are going to be catastrophic and
they can be fixed quickly and
unfortunately we don't have any more
time for questions but thanks a lot to
our speaker
[Music]
you